اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم غموض مصير مؤسسي شركه
فاجنر السلطات الروسيه اعلنت اجراء تحقيق
في تحطم طائراته شمال موسكو في وقت اكدته
مصادر فيفا
على قائمه الركاب واعلنت العثور على هاتفه
قربه احدى الجثث
وفي ردود الفعل على هذه الحادثه رئيس
الاوكراني ينفي اي صله لبلاده باسقاط
طائره مؤسس فاجنر ومسؤولون امريكيون
يقولون ان صاروخ ارض جو مصدر روسيا على
الارجح هو الذي اسقط الطائره بينما تحدثت
باريس عن مواصفاتها بشكوك المنطقيه بشان
ظروف تحطم الطائره
اختتام اعمال قمه مجموعه بريكس بالموافقه
على انضمام كل من السعوديه وايران ومصر
والامارات والارجنتين واثيوبيا وزيره
الخارجات السعودي شدد على ان المجموعه
ستظل مصدرا موثوقا للطاقه بينما اكد رئيس
الصيني لنظره الايراني تعزيز التعاون ضمن
بريكس وغيرها من التكتلات
فنلندا التي تعد اكبر منتجا لفروه الثعالب
في اوروبا تبدا باعدام 120 الفا من
الثعالب وحيوان الملك وذلك بهدف وقف
انتشار انفلونزا الطيور اذا ادى ارتفاع
عدد الاصابات بالانفلونزا الى دعوات لفرض
حظر على صناعه الفراء في دول في شمال
اوروبا الى اللقاء